is the tendency of an organism to evolve
towards its childhood uh morphology yeah
and so okay so neotness
averaged females are more attractive
yeah and so now is that just out of
curiosity do you think that the
attractiveness of that neotni is a
consequence of the ability of the more
childlike face to elicit care from a
male
yeah illicit care and interest and you
know attractiveness
[Music]
foreign
hello everybody I'm pleased to have with
me today one of the world's great
biologists Dr Randy Thornhill he's an
evolutionary biologist and distinguished
professor of biology Emeritus at the
University of New Mexico
with a primary interest in animal
behavior and psychology as well as human
behavior and psychology Dr Thornhill and
his colleagues have authored or
co-authored about 250 scientific
Publications including four research
monographs or books his Publications
have been cited in the scientific
literature more than 35
000 times a citation score is the number
of times a reference to a given piece of
research is cited by another researcher
or in another publication by the same
author
a scientific citation count in the tens
of thousands clearly indicates that a
researcher occupies a position in the
upper echelons of scientific influence
Dr Thornhill is a founder of the
research disciplines of Behavioral
ecology evolutionary psychology
evolutionary Aesthetics that's the study
of the experience of Beauty from an
evolutionary perspective Evolution and
human behavior the modern study of
adaptation and the study of sexual
coercion
Dr Thornhill thank you very much for
agreeing to talk to me today
thank you for inviting me pleasure to be
here thank you thank you so I've come
across your research a number of times
in my career struck by its uh its
originality and and its impact I I'd
like to ask you first about something I
I probably ran into maybe it's 20 years
ago maybe it's 15 something like that
you did some work on the perception of
attractiveness bilateral symmetry
averageness and sexual selection can you
outline what you found and why
yes
um I did work some years ago now and uh
human uh attractiveness and
um that turned out to to be very uh
productive about attractiveness in
general in animals and one of the key uh
traits
that animals look at
in judging uh physical attractiveness of
Partners of Mates is a bilateral
symmetry and a colleague and I in the
early 90s came up with a way to measure
uh facial symmetry in humans it had been
worked on before and but the
measurements that they used were didn't
work so we came up with a with a method
that did work measuring bilateral
symmetry in the face so that is the
symmetry of the two sides of the face
why is that important and why is it a
marker for attractiveness it turns out
that that bilateral symmetry is a
measure of Developmental health
and so the the organism uh when it
starts developing it's designed by
evolution by selection
to to uh achieve a bilaterally symmetric
form you can think of that this is the
case when I say organisms I mean all
forward moving organisms all forward
moving organisms uh have uh have have
adaptations developmental adaptations to
achieve a bilaterally symmetric body
because first of all that reduces drag
so if you're moving forward
and your bilaterally symmetric you don't
have any drag in your movement you can
think about a person with a leg a bit
shorter than the other and there's drag
in the move in the forward movement the
more of that asymmetry the more drag so
you lose efficiency and movement
that's fundamental to what bilateral
symmetry is about but next bilateral
symmetry is very hard perfect bilateral
symmetry is a big very hard to achieve
by development so it's a marker of
quality of the individual pertaining to
its developmental Health we see in many
things that human beings design to move
forward bilateral symmetry cars or
automobiles are bilaterally symmetrical
airplanes are bilaterally symmetrical so
we like our world to be that way yeah we
like the world to be that way actually
it turns out and uh well you're
associating it if you had if you had one
side of the car uh asymmetric compared
to the other side of the car then it'd
be more drag you know it's not in a fish
you'd use more gas think about it that
way uh in driving down the road with an
asymmetric car
um but so this this is one component of
physical attractiveness bilateral
symmetry and we looked first when we
developed this uh way to measure facial
symmetry uh that became a a very hot
research topic we did the first and then
others followed very quickly
lots and lots of research has been done
now but there's you know symmetry of
movement that's important in how fluid
one's movement is and how attractive
therefore one's movement is you're not
dragging your foot or whatever
and um all that is really a component
of the importance of Health in physical
attractiveness So Physical
attractiveness fundamentally is a health
certification that's how we judge
people's attractiveness we don't think
about it consciously it's an unconscious
calculation of the traits important in
uh health and developmental Health as
bilateral symmetry is one of these so
you measure the symmetry of the two
sides of the face and we showed in our
first study of this way back now that
um that measurement uh relates to how
attractive faces are perceived traffic
is in the same sex or opposite sex and
then that research went on to look at uh
kids looking at faces and different
ethnic groups looking at faces it works
like a charm wherever you do it lots and
lots of preservatives and so does it
mean that if you show people symmetrical
or asymmetrical faces that they
obviously have a preference for the
symmetrical faces will they look longer
at the symmetrical faces will infants
look longer at symmetrical faces yes
they do yeah that's the way the infant
infant Beauty research is done you just
look at whether the whether the baby and
they got it down down to almost newborns
you know looking at faces and
um judging these faces basically on the
basis of Interest how long they look at
the face versus getting distracted to
something else and symmetry is one
compar part of the uh Beauty whether
you're talking about babies or kids or
old people or young people or whatever
facial symmetry is is very important
it's not the only Beauty marker in the
face we look at we can talk about that
in a moment too because that gets us
into some other research we've done but
symmetry is a very important one now
that research went on to look at how
symmetry plays out in the everyday lives
of people and we did the initial studies
on that but again that that research
bloomed and uh lots of people have done
it and still it's an active part of
research but the first thing we did not
just attractiveness we did a bunch of
that in relation to symmetry but we
looked at sex lives of people
romantically paired people
studies of couples and looked at uh
looked at
reports by men and women of sex partner
numbers they've had in their lifetime
that was one component of them because
that's that's a that's a measure in Men
in particular of uh what biologists call
mating success so number of number of
sexual partners one has and uh that that
research showed that for men the more
symmetric the man uh the more sex
partners he had and a technical tale
there after we you know initially
started with facial symmetry but then we
moved to the body of people we came up
with a metric for body symmetry
measuring 11 traits
on both sides of the body
these traits are ear length and air
width
um and and then we measure elbow there's
some elbow anatomy there that we measure
some bones wrists fingers all those men
measured of course on both sides measure
foot width ankle width Trace like that
and we put that together in a composite
as a measure of body bilateral symmetry
that correlates highly with facial
symmetry because the Symmetry is a
developmental Health measure throughout
the body
and um that correlates with mating
success of men a more more symmetric men
are physically more attractive and they
have more sex partners we also got into
um looking at Men's infidelities in
their relationships and found that more
symmetric men engage in more meetings
outside the parabon as well so that's
that's part of their mating success we
did uh the first study of
uh kind of modern study we would call it
of female orgasm uh in relation in in uh
copulatory orgasm uh so in part looking
at women uh 200 romantically paired
couples
and asking the women about their orgasm
patterns during mating with their
partner and separately asking the men
and we found that the men's reports and
the women's reports a frequency of
copulatory orgasm by the women were very
highly correlate it so men are paying
attention to this phenomenon of whether
the female is sexually aroused to the
Zenith level of orgasm of course and
more symmetric man we're firing uh more
copulatory orgasms too that was a very
classic study in human so I have a
specific question about that I've always
wanted to ask a biologist interested in
sexual behavior but I know that there's
been a lot of discussion about the
hypothetical evolutionary purpose of
female orgasm and I was wondering if
female orgasm is
disproportionately likely to trigger
trigger male orgasm
I guess it could be it could be an
adaptation that's used to elicit
pregnancy essentially yeah I don't think
it is it's there's no there's there's no
evidence
that females that orgasm very
infrequently
have fewer babies
and actually women who don't ever orgasm
can be quite fertile so I don't think
it's fundamentally that I think what it
is
it's part of female mate choice
and more and more basically sire choice
of the female let me explain
so when a female has an orgasm
uh she has uterine contraction of course
and that pull it works like a suction it
pulls the uh content of the vagina up to
the cervix
so it puts the puts the content of the
vagina
in a good place and if that content
includes the males ejaculate then she's
pulling the males ejaculate up to the
cervix where it's easier for him to get
you know either for the ejaculate to get
into the right place to conceive so if
she imagine a female who has two mating
partners
she orgasms with one
pulling his ejaculate up to the cervix
and she skips orgasm with the other
partner so she in effect has mated with
both men
so that is you know same mating success
of the two men if you just look at
mating success but she's doing something
more subtle
that is differentially affecting the
fertilizing capacity of the ejaculate of
the two men the men the ejaculate she
pulls up has more potential for
fertilization and that's a component of
cryptic female choice
so uh in the 80s I discovered uh what I
labeled as cryptic female Choice first
in insects and then uh it applied to uh
female orgasm uh too in uh in humans
as an encrypted female choice is it's
just the the kind of female choice
that is invisible if you're only
measuring mating success so in the
example we talked about the two guys
mating with this female had the same
mating success they both Mater but one
had was was preferred over the other by
the females orgasmic capacity with him
that pulled his ejaculate up and so
females by showing this differential uh
um orgasm pattern that I described with
symmetry are favoring symmetric Partners
over other men and hypothetically
healthier partners and and yeah
with an advantage that's right higher
genetic quality and then that's that's
an issue behind all this discussion so
far is that uh female
organisms uh are after uh High genetic
Quality Partners when when the you know
to be fathers of their offspring so it's
a sire choice or the cryptic female
choice is more of a sire Choice than
just a mate choice and darwinian Darwin
Charles Darwin discovered uh female
choice and did a lot with it for sure
and biologists had viewed
um female choice in a darwinian
framework up until very recently until
the cryptic female Choice came along but
females are far more sophisticated than
just choosing one male over another as a
mate they do they do these subtle things
and involved in cryptic choice to prefer
some uh the uh sperm of some mates over
the sperm of others a whole Suite of
gnats that's a big area well what other
elements are what other elements make up
cryptic choice you you describe the
orgasm what else
it was was in some insects called
scorpion flies and what the females do
there
is they adjust mating duration
and hence the amount of ejaculate that
the male transfers there's no orgasm in
these insects but the longer the male
can mate the long the bigger his the
more sperm he transfers to the female so
females are adjusting ejaculate duration
on the base of body size of the male
so and about bigger males are more fit
males and so forth better growth and
more resources growing up the higher
quality males the females are receiving
more sperm from bigger males that's one
thing I did with these insects another
was the female after she mates with a
male makes a choice of whether to lay
eggs or not
if she chooses to lay eggs then she will
fertilize you know from other research
I've done she will fertilize those eggs
with the last male sperm she mated with
so if she makes the decision lay eggs
she's going to use that last male sperm
sheet and and large males again are
preferred and that component of cryptic
female choice so cryptically if in these
female scorpion funds are preferring
large-bodied males by both receiving
more sperm from them and making
decisions to lay eggs with them and not
other males so those kind of subtle
things that females do that aren't
apparent if you're just measuring
classical
meals mating success you know and his
symmetry in in human beings is it
associate It's associated with longevity
is it associated with decreased
probability of disease in the future is
it associated with higher General
cognitive ability like are there other
things that for cognitive ability we did
that we did that research and that's now
there have been uh three or four
repetitions of our initial research
we did it on 200 uh
subjects uh similarly so University
students the psych who will kind of
study and uh measured uh measured IQ
uh using a culture Fair measure of IQ
culture Fair uh procedure and uh
questionnaire measured that cue and then
measured the Symmetry in it for both
sexes the uh higher the symmetry of the
individual the higher the IQ so do you
remember the size of the relationship by
any chance that was that one was about
0.3 it's a it's a moderate uh
relationship for IQ
um the you know there's measurement
error and I measure and IQ there's
measurement error and measuring
developmental stability as symmetry too
uh so you know we measure 10 11 traits
if we measured 50 traits presumably we
would get a correlation of say 0.8 with
IQ you know what I mean there's all that
measurement and the IQ relationship
would exist hypothetically because the
healthier individual would be prone to a
more favorable pattern of of
neurological development over the course
of life that's the idea exactly the uh
some colleagues went on to look at
uh some brain features in relation to
developmental stability of the outer
body
so they did uh uh
Imaging uh brain Imaging studies to look
at certain brain Parts some brain parts
are bilaterally asymmetric by Design
so I want bigger on one side than Corpus
glow well the corpus callosum is a tube
you know that connects the two
hemispheres that's just a size Factor
but you can measure the size of that
circumference of the corpus callosum as
they did and the bigger the bigger the
tube the higher the uh body symmetry of
the person bigger the corpus callosum
they measured a couple of other brain
Parts too and showing that um showing
that so you can talk about a modal
directionality
for an asymmetric trait
so there's a there's a mode the most
common degree of asymmetry in an
asymmetric trait so like handedness and
so forth
uh six is you know the average person or
the modal person is 60 right 40 left
hand use
you can measure deviation from that
as another measure of Developmental
instability
and that was the kind of thing they did
with the brain Parts these asymmetric
brain parts so that's that's deviation
from averageness in a sense in a sense
now you also did work on averageness and
attractiveness get some stuff on the
averaging this but we're really just to
control it because uh you can do average
facial uh features you know no size eye
size lip size uh their measurements of
the face right and people have built
Composites of faces to produce average
faces and had people rate them average
averageness average faces is a more
attractive than non-average however
average is not the op the most
attractive face
the most attractive faces deviate from
average in predictable ways you want to
talk about it sure yes okay
so I've seen averaged models faces and
they seem more attractive than averaged
faces and maybe that yeah well yeah but
you you can take a model and you can
make you know make her
a knock drop dead by the by the
following computer manipulations
what you do if she's a female model not
a male model if she's a female model you
do the estrogen modifications on her on
her face
through computer techniques so you you
reduce basically lower face size
she inside jaw size those kinds of
things that are under estrogen control
during puberty and Adolescence
and for a male face you manipulate in
the opposite direction so male faces are
more attractive when testosterone it's
not estrogenized and female faces are
more attractive when estrogenized so the
female model facial models get their get
their job because they're highly
estrogenized faces and are they
neotenous the female attractive faces
are they more neotness
yeah they're more neotenous in a sense
of
so so a a woman who makes her living
with her face
uh face model
her face is about the size lower face is
about the same size as a 10 11 year old
girl so neotni in that sense so New York
knee is the tendency of an organism to
evolve towards its childhood uh apology
yeah and so okay so neotnes new yorkness
averaged females are more attractive
yeah and so now is that just out of
curiosity do you think that the
attractiveness of that neotni is a
consequence of the ability of the more
childlike face to elicit care from a
male
yeah illicit care and interest and you
know attractiveness so basically here's
the way we think it works
so the so the neotni we're talking about
we could talk about it just as degree of
estrogenization of the face that's what
we measure
um
that is a marker of Health in a
different sense hormonal health
so estrogen estrogen is fundamentally
the fertility and reproductive
capability hormone of the female mammal
estrogen
so the more estrogenized she is
the greater her fertility and
reproductive capacity is so that's what
we're responding to in the physical
attractiveness of a female is there an
association between average niotinous
faces and optimal ways to hip ratio
yeah well the yeah the the
estrogenization
affects not only the facial features it
affects bones and so forth so you know
uh petite people talk about petite women
uh as as attractive she's so petite and
so forth what they're talking about is
estrogenization or bones throughout the
body not just the face but uh and that
includes the uh the waist hip ratio
is really a marker
of degree of estrogenization of the
female body low-waisted ratio so a small
waist relative to a more expanded hips
the smaller the waist relative to the
hips is a marker of estrogenization of
the female body and that again is a is a
marker of female reproductive capacity
through the estrogen effect and that's
optimal at about 0.68 is that is that
really research yeah yeah you're you're
you know underwear models female
underwear models they're down they could
go as low as 0.66 or 0.68 you can uh be
a model
yeah
so what other elements of attractive
okay so a couple of things here so the
first thing that's really quite
interesting is that your work points to
or this work this this entire line of
work points to a profound biological
basis for the uh experience of aesthetic
attraction at least in relationship to
the perception of other people and of
course the perception of ourselves
you're right that's a tremendous amount
of thoughts grounded in Instinct
apparently yeah
and it's it's an instinct that's
manifest so early that you see the
preference for attractive faces say
measured by averageness in newborns do
you see the same preference for
testosteroneized males and estrogenized
females among newborns there's anyone
looked at that yeah uh yeah
uh kids and down to
um very recently born kids
have been looked at in terms of their
judgment of men's faces too
and that's they're looking at
testosterone features there mask you
know you call it masculinity would be
the common but testosterone technically
and um these features that grow under
the influence of testosterone during
puberty and Adolescence
uh in the mail and then the female
they're growing under the influence of
estrogen basically estrogen just capping
the growth of those facial bones and the
other bones too and the testosterone
along with growth hormone promotes the
growth of the same bones in the face and
body of the man
and uh so babies are judging men's faces
the same as you and I or a person off
the street but uh that's what the that's
what the research shows yeah
this was promoted there's a book called
The Beauty myth for example that
purports to claim that conceptions of
female Beauty are what would you say uh
arbitrary social constructions what do
you think about that idea how powerful
is the biological impulse towards
aesthetic experience it's the it's the
reality
the bio the biological research I'm
referring to has been so abundant since
the uh really starting in the 90s that
what really kicked it off was uh the
stuff we did initially on Symmetry and
then then then researchers got into the
hormone markers uh Beauty markers
involving hormonal health and then most
recently it has been there's been
another drive to look at uh
uh some pigment issues uh in terms of a
beauty marker a carotenoid pigment in
particular
but it's all health
uh it's all hell and the beauty myth
yeah I forgot her name Naomi Klein yeah
right
um that was just uh just blank ideology
granting yeah had nothing to do with
reality and and then there was enough
known about uh sexual selection
processes and uh animals to
cast that idea and you know and uh in
doubt but since then it's just uh that's
right well because you see this
preferences that you've been describing
you see analogs of those invariants of
them across the entire Animal Kingdom
and you see the preference in newborns
so it's pretty hard to construct a
social constructionist view of the
aesthetic experience of attractiveness
given all that information right well
the first study on symmetry that I did
uh the role of symmetry and sexual
selection
uh competition for mates and mate choice
that was done on insects
at the same time unknown to me uh a Dane
a Danish biologist was studying
barswallops and tail Symmetry and barn
swallows and we co-discovered this role
of symmetry and sexual selection
independently he's working on bar
swallows in Europe I was working on
Scorpion flies uh and then I got into
humans too but yeah and then following
that biologists working on all kinds of
Critters you know looked at the Symmetry
Paradigm in Deer
in their favorite study animal and uh I
think by 19 let's see
about 1997-98
75 species
of animals that have been shown in which
symmetry plays an important role in the
sexual selection system of the animals
yeah
so it's very robust say the least
so so fundamentally we find we we use
markers of attractiveness for for across
both sexes to indicate General Health
and more than health is it also an
indicator of General competence It's
associated with General cognitive
ability what about personality markers
has anybody looked at that like are are
people who are symmetrical are they less
likely to be high in negative emotion
for example or we look for it
um the guy did most of the research on
sex
and symmetry in humans he's a he's a
psychologist
and um you know Works in a psychology
department I'm a psychologist too but I
don't work in a psychology department
but um and we got right into looking at
personality thinking it might correlate
with personality and nothing and others
have tried it too so it's not a symmetry
is not a part of the personality
Paradigm yeah yeah well it's not it's
not obvious that that there's an optimal
personality perhaps that's part of it is
that there seems to be niches for
personality that are useful for all
sorts of different personalities I mean
it looks all things considered like
higher General cognitive ability is
better across multiple domains but it's
not so obvious with personality so maybe
that's part of the reason that's not so
robust I was wondering more with
sensitivity to negative emotion because
I thought maybe that less healthy people
would be higher in trait neuroticism and
that might show up with symmetry but you
haven't found anything like that yeah no
we we didn't we didn't find anything
that was condensing there I see what
you're saying though that would be a
reasonable prediction to you know and
then the personality domain we can get
into that when we start talking about
the parasite stress yeah so let's let's
move into the parasite stress Theory now
apart before we do let me before we do
uh let me just summarize the beauty
thing in in
two minutes great so the current
knowledge the reality about
uh
our judgments of fiscal attractiveness
uh Imperial empirically based uh
knowledge the only kind of knowledge
There's real knowledge but empirically
based knowledge of how we judge physical
attractiveness in terms of facial and
bodily attractiveness
is we use Health markers and those
Health markers are developmental
stability that's symmetry
hormonal health
that's another one
and senescence is a third
so as we age uh we lose attractiveness
of course and and we lose function and
two and so we pay attention to age and
senescence affects when we judge
attractiveness of course so symmetry
hormonal effects and um and senescence
then the final one this the most recent
marker of physical attractiveness that
has been discovered
is the uh carotenoid pigment uh thing
and it's pretty wild
um so carotenoids you you can't make we
don't animals don't make right noise you
get them from diet
we we eat carotenoid-based Foods or um
or animals that have eaten
carotenoid-based Foods so you get you
get all of our carotenoids and the
carotenoids are very important in
metabolism so uh fundamental to
metabolic you got to have a lot of noise
if you've got a lot of carotenoids then
you and you've got excess carotenoids
you put those carotenoids in your skin
and then the yellow colors in skin
and the yellow tints in skin and doesn't
have anything to do with uh what your uh
it's a racial background is or whatever
you could there's there's yellowness in
the skin of uh African Americans uh
Caucasians or uh whatever Asians there's
yellow pigment there the degree of
yellow
is important and attractiveness we
assess it when we look at when we look
at faces the more yellow the more
carotenoid the person has the more
excess the carotenoid the person has can
put it in their skin and what
carotenoids says
is that you have to you have to have a
healthy gut
to absorb carotenoid
it's fat soluble you can't absorb fat if
your gut's sick so it's uh the
yellowness in skin is a uh is a marker
another marker of help that we use and
that's only been discovered in the last
15 years or so from what foods are
carotenoids derived uh your fruits and
vegetables for the you know they're full
of carotenoids so you want to eat a lot
of those
uh and you get so is it also a marker of
your ability to provision yourself
well that too but you can provision
yourself in anything and you know it
doesn't show up in your skin right so
but that's not a higher quality marker
of provisioning and it's just no it's a
sign of metabolic Health right right
yeah if you're if you're you know
healthy uh body looking and stuff no
that that's a that's a that's a good
indicator but this is specifically
uh related to your overall gut health
and allow you know so is it reasonable
to say now that we know enough about the
biology of attractiveness that we could
build an optimally attractive form
purely based on the scientific data
pertaining to health markers yeah
I can take a female I can take a female
model famous facial model
and take that face digitize that face
into the computer like off the cover of
Cosmopolitan or whatever and I've done
this
and I can make that make her even more
attractive
through uh through reducing uh the uh
increasing the estrogenization
components of her face I could make her
more attractive then she so if I if I
want to be particularly successful on
Tinder I'd put up a representation of my
face but I'd make it bilaterally
symmetrical so I could duplicate maybe
the left side of my face I'd I'd make my
skin yellower
yeah make your skin a little yellower oh
yeah you can do it I mean that their
last most recent research on the
yellowness things right on this thing is
people would uh do you do they did
experiments where
they put people on different diets
and they measure their you know take
their facial picture before the
experiment in six weeks after in six
weeks you can improve your facial
attractiveness by carotenoid including
more crotonin here in your diet so it
could be pretty quick and students love
this when we talk about in class of
course and tell them tell them how to
get prettier in a hurry
yeah all right so let's move to to the
next major topic I came across your work
on parasite stress Theory a few years
ago I started to get interest there was
a burgeoning literature on the role of
disgust in political uh
and I ran across your parasite stress
Theory and so and you were looking to
begin with that the relationship between
parasite stress and values and so maybe
we could delve first of all into well
what parasite stress is and how you
would study that in relationship to
value and why you would ever think to do
that because it's by no means obvious
okay so the parasite stress what we call
the parasite stress theory of values uh
we also call it the parasite stress
theory of sociality
is uh is a scientific theory
uh about how people get their values so
the causes of people's values and the
theory is a theory about both proximate
causation and ultimate causation so in
biology there are two general categories
of causation Proxima and ultimate
proximate causation has to do with
causes of something that occurred during
the lifetime of the animal
events during the lifetime that cause
whatever effect you're looking at that's
approximate causes ultimate causation
has to do with causes in the Deep time
past evolutionary past ultimate equal
evolutionary approximate equal causes
during the lifetime of the individual
and this theory of parasite stress
theory of values is both approximate
ultimate
theory about how we get our causes so
let's start start with the approximate
level of causation
of our values and what I mean by values
so that's that's a kind of a big topic
uh if you look at the history of
research on values
um it is it is uh it is very large but
we could take we could and and almost uh
Unbound it what psychologists have
called uh values so value would be
something like rank ordered preference
if we're going to Define value itself
right because we have to choose between
things
that's yeah that's value okay so we were
talking about the value people place on
looking at one face versus another
that's a value that's a preference right
and they'll donate more attentional
resources to high value faces because
attention is a marker of value
right but we can talk about what
psychologists have called values and the
study of bad use and that's a big big
area of research values research and uh
the history of it and all is really
really cool but anyway but we could we
could sort of bound this discussion of
values
in what political science uh refer to as
values and what they refer to as values
is the political dimension of uh highly
conservative to highly liberal so it's a
Continuum of values and you can measure
uh a person's values they've worked hard
to come up with ways to measure a
person's values you measure a person's
values you can put that person on that
Continuum somewhere everybody can be put
on that continue from uh psychometric
procedure questionnaires
that so the political scientists have
done values that way across cultural
psychologists have done values in terms
of collectivism and individualism that
dimension
with collectivism High collectivism
being low individualism uh individualism
being low uh collectivism and it turns
out if you look at these two dimensions
a one from uh psychology collectivism
individualism one from political
scientists uh conservatism liberalism
they correspond so high collectivism is
conservatism High liberalism is
individualism and uh so you can you can
think about look what I'm talking about
in terms of core values by those those
two Dimensions the conservatism
liberalism and collectivism
individualism and basically as I show uh
they are as we show uh that those those
uh measures uh those dimensions are very
very similar if not identical could you
take them apart a little bit and talk
about collectivism conservatism and and
liberalism individualism so everybody
knows I will indeed yeah excellent yeah
so uh
you measure these you measure these uh a
person's collectivism said differently
you measure his or her individualism
and uh uh you're what you're measuring
so let's talk let's start start first
with with conservatism
so
uh conservative person has sub the sub
components of this value system
so the person has believes uh
importantly in traditional things
traditional things and parochial things
local
uh also the person is uh relatively
xenophobic
uh if conservative people are relatively
xenophobic and xenophobia is fear
dislike avoidance of stuff on the
outside foreigners people new ideas so
xenophobia has a neophobia component
neophobia means phobia about the new
so you like traditional stuff you don't
like new you don't like foreign
so conservatives uh have uh have the
xenophobia
the traditionalism parochialism they
also uh are high in ethnocentrism
ethnocentrism uh is uh uh a preference
for people like you you're in group you
define your in-group that starts with
your with your
um with your nuclear family but then
extends an extended family and others
with like values like you so that's your
ethnocentric uh component and another
component of conservatism is uh liking
to just stay home so Philip Patrick uh
love of where you're born you stay there
your whole life and so forth and they're
highly conservative and highly
conservative cultures you don't know
much
so that's conservatism and then the the
antipol of those values really
characterizes uh uh individualism or
liberalism so instead of xenophobic
you're xenophilic you like people that
are different from you you're
comfortable with other kinds of people
even if they have different values even
if they have a different color even if
they believe differently you're more
comfortable with those than you are if
you're conservative
and um ethnocentric uh esocentrism is
low under individualism
in in the more nuclear family oriented
than extended family oriented
and uh you're you're in group is really
composed of people with all kinds of
different beliefs and maybe colors and
so forth backgrounds as as an
individualistic or a liberal
and you're more prone to moving around
you've got Frontier Spirit movement and
adventure and going new places is is a
good idea you got a passport uh if
you're living so those are those are
some some big differences uh between the
two and you know the two polls and is it
is it how how much is that do you
suppose is it preference for familiarity
versus preference for novelty is that at
the core no that's that's at the core
that's that's part of the neophobia you
could you could put that under the
neophobia so the fear avoidance dislike
of new and that can be new ideas it can
be new types of folks it can be new new
discussions all those kinds of things
are avoided and it's just it just you
know most generally it characterizes
outside okay so so let me ask you a
really specific question about that
because you could think about that two
ways you could think about that as
avoidance of the unfamiliar and dislike
of the unfamiliar or you could think
about it as marked preference for the
familiar and then on the other side you
could think about it as marked
preference for the novel you know rather
than it being is it against something or
for something or is it both on both
sides it's both I mean against the
against can go all the way to hate you
know under under high xenophobia hate
and even uh you know we get into how uh
conservatism and traditional societies
and so forth promotes uh inner group
aggression Warfare to the point where
you not only hate those Outsiders you
want to kill them
and um so you have both components that
there the the out group The avoidance as
well as the
um interest in in
socializing with people that are like
you yeah okay okay so you know we've got
the values Dimensions nailed down and so
on to the parasite stress yeah so when
you start looking at conservatism let's
start there the
um the connections
to parasites
jumped out at us and let me try to
explain
so with xenophobia okay
you want to avoid those people over
there that are different from you okay
and that's that's tied to a very
fundamental part
of uh host parasite co-evolution so the
way host parasite coevolution works
is that
uh it's it's ongoing
and it's antagonistic and the parasite
is trying to evolve to eat the host the
host is evolving defenses against the
parasite and that continues uh in
Forever you never get out of your host
parasite Coalition a race
so
you get this Coalition race between
hosts and parasites and uh much and much
much research shows how localized those
covolutionary races are geographically
localized
so you get different strains of TB in
different neighborhoods in a big city in
Morocco for example it's geographically
very uh very uh uh localized these host
parasite Coalition and races which means
that locally you're relatively immune to
the parasites but the parasites on the
outside and those people on the outside
in the out groups those parasites you're
not uh immune to so that's why you have
xenophobia
uh it is a way to avoid uh foreign
parasites that you're not uh evolved to
deal with immunologically that's the
xenophobia component so that's
contamination it's avoidance of
contamination
right and yeah from from parasites that
you're not immune to because you're
relatively immune to the local the local
and you're set you're safe with people
that are just like you okay they're
local people because they've got
immunity like yours and yours is
relatively good against the local
parasites but not the foreign parasites
because of foreign parasites because of
this
localization of the host host uh
parasite coagulation right and so you're
saying that you don't have to go very
far away before you go you don't have
trouble very far away no all these new
strains of covid popping up uh they're
you know they're going to be lots and
lots and lots of lots and lots of
strains and the uh you hear about some
of the strains now they're eight or ten
or something like that but they're
they're uh they're popping up and and uh
uh you know either more of them they're
the surveillance on this new strains is
pretty limited so far haven't done a lot
of that because he's been doing other
things with a pandemic but still you get
that you get that occurring with the
covet too this localization of the
strains you know there's a South African
strain and so forth so on UK strain and
all that so
um you don't have to go very far okay
for the localization of the immunity you
have to not work so well
and that's where the Philip Hatchery
comes in too so Philip Patrick you just
stay home you stay home you interact
with people that are immunologically
like you and therefore are safe
relatively safe
rather than dispersing to interact with
foreigners and the habitats that may
contain these these parasites you're not
adapted to so that's Philip Patrick
component
the ethnocentric component
uh is
related to so when the diseases come
you want to have a lot of local social
support
so you have all these ties with extended
family and so forth that's your social
support and in ethnographic societies
traditional societies anthropologists
have done a lot of research on how
important it is to have
can that will help you when you get sick
that's the only way you can you can make
it you have Ken and kit and Friends uh
locally that that help you that's that's
the ethnocentric part all right so if
there's if there's a high probability of
illness uh occurring then you're more
dependent in reality on your closest
Network you're an American and your
friends your close friends exactly the
higher the parasite stress is in a
region
the more likely it those those parasites
are going to come eventually and and so
you got to have that social support
that's important uh for dealing and
getting through you and your family
getting through the parasite uh crunch
so that's why the ethnocentrism Phillip
Hatchery and uh xenophobia components
and those have you know the component
another part you know subparts of that
we talked about openness to experience
new experiences uh and all that that's
part of a part of really neophobia right
so we okay so there's a personality so
in a couple of specific questions about
that for you so
the best predictors of conservatism from
a personality perspective are openness
to experience low yeah and one
sub-asspect or one aspect of
conscientiousness which is orderliness
now I noticed in your research you
looked at extroversion and openness
together and you you saw that the more
collectivist slash conservative types
who are protecting themselves according
to parasite stress Theory from
contamination are likely to be more
introverted and lower in openness and
that means less exploratory in general
because those two things together seem
to maybe make up exploratory Behavior
but there is good personality data
showing that the orderly part of
conscientiousness is also a predictor of
conservatism and yeah that I don't know
if I don't know if there's been any data
because that's a more microanalysis in
relationships nobody's looked at that
component but absolutely orderliness is
very fundamental to conservatism it
won't order
disorder is chaos from the standpoint of
a conservative mind you know you want
order and everything yeah and chaos is
see I've thought and this is interesting
too because maybe we could talk a little
bit about the the emotions that are
elicited here so for the longest time I
was I had been thinking about the
conservative collectivist viewpoint
every in relationship to novelty in two
two elements two manners one is that the
more conservative mind doesn't get as
much of a positive emotional kick out of
novelty and exploration right because
that that's fundamentally motivating if
you have the personality type that's
associated with exploratory Behavior but
then there's this idea of phobia too
like neophobia but you know
conservatives aren't higher in
neuroticism and so and that and that's
really a striking finding because if
anything it turns out that at least
under some conditions liberals seem to
be higher in trait and autism but
there's a role of disgust that seems to
be under examined and is it is it is the
neophobia a consequence of fear or is it
a consequence of disgust which seems
more tightly associated with immunity as
opposed to say fear Yeah well yeah I
mean you know you can
you can get prejudice
toward an out group
that has fear components and discuss
components I mean you can be absolutely
disgusted you know how to conservative
person who uh has to interact with an
out group will might even happen to
discuss face how to discuss it but it's
also I mean I think you see that with
food for example yeah right you get it
with food or uh you know any any kind of
pathogen threat can evoke
discussed this emotion of discuss uh in
uh you know in a person and the more
conservative they are the more likely to
get the actual disgust reaction yeah
well and discussion you know moral
violation food for rotten food dirty
toilet all that stuff yeah
so that that's some account like people
have struggled for a long time to make
sense of dietary prohibitions in
religious contexts for example and and I
mean if if you have dietary restrictions
and markers for in-group uh
identification that's a good way of
deciding or of determining consistently
who's on your side and also marking
who's on the other side yeah
all kinds of things come into play to
indicate boundary between boundaries
well okay so when I was looking at
thinking about the relationship you know
there's there's five basic personality
dimensions and ten aspects and so but
only two of them really really strongly
predict political affiliation and that's
openness so high openness is liberalism
and and and uh orderliness Which is less
powerful predictor but so the
conservatives are low in openness and
high and orderliness and I thought why
in the world do those two
uncorrelated personality predictors
co-vary to predict political belief and
then I thought over a number of years
that it has to be it has to do with
borders is the fundamental political
question is the conservative likes
thick borders between everything and the
liberal wants thin borders and the
liberal wants thin borders because their
Niche is the Locale where information is
transferred
and but the code the the the the counter
tendency is the conservative tendency to
say yeah but if you're aware the
information is going to be transferred
because the borders are thin you're
probably going to get sick and die
and they're both right
yeah
seem reasonable yeah right in terms of
what is well sometimes the conservatives
are right that you're going to die if
you get if you expose yourself to what's
new and sometimes the Liberals are right
in that you need what's new to renew you
right well these these values that we
acquire are very strategic and they're
uh you know they're they're suitable for
our understanding of the culture that we
live in they're suitable for that
they're optimal for that so if you grow
up we haven't really talked about the
evidence yet behind the paracetious
theory but and that'll give that your
comments skip get me into that
um so we looked at we looked at
um the theory in relation to
um what it predicts to test it so it
predicts that the you know if you take
measures of parasite stress across the
world
uh countries or states of the United
States or whatever that that will
correspond to conservative or
collectivist values measured by
um measured by political sinus these
measures and put in the literature for
countries and states measures of
psychologists of individualism
collectivism put into the literature so
we pull those data and look for the
predictive relationship between parasite
stress and uh conservatism and
liberalism and found uh what we expected
and strongly so the more parasites the
more conservative said differently the
more parasites the more collectivists
and so does that broadly mean the more
infectious diseases yes and so yeah more
there's two two ways basically uh We've
measured or several ways now we've
measured infectious disease levels so by
parasite I mean any infectious agent it
doesn't mean just intestinal worms or
some something is any infectious agent
so virus bacterium worms whatever level
of parasites you're talking about is a
parasite
infectious disease synonymous with
infectious disease so uh you can take
number of infectious diseases per
country for example
you can take number of infectious
diseases per state for the U.S
or you can take the rate of infection so
that the
proportion of the population that has
each of these infectious diseases in an
area so either number of infectious
diseases are the prevalence of the
infectious diseases and either of those
very strongly and similarly predicts uh
the values with more infectious diseases
more conservatism that is more
collectivism the fewer infectious
diseases the more liberalism that's done
on just Geographic level but then and we
did all that initially and then um
and then others came along quickly
actually once it got started and it's
still it's still uh really blooming out
there all the research on the parasite
stress Theory values done by people all
over the world now but uh people started
doing it at the individual level so you
take a bring a person into the lab
and you show them cues of uh immediate
parasite danger so these are just like a
slideshow with uh with disease cues in
it so dirty toilet a person with skin
pox a person sneezing those kinds of
those kinds of cues so they see these
slots and then you measure their values
before and after seeing the slots
and uh you have an immediate effect
amazing immediate effect you can so let
me talk about the power of these of
these relationships so if I remember
correctly some of the data that your
team generated showed that the
correlation between infectious disease
prevalence so parasite stress and
conservatism was as high as 0.7 yeah so
staggering un unprecedented strength
that's stronger than the relationship
between General cognitive ability or
it's as strong as the relationship
between General cognitive ability and
learning which is the strongest
Association I've ever seen in social
sciences yeah yeah yeah we get some big
effects on I mean there's Barry they're
very in terms of what particular
prediction we're looking at and we've
looked across so many domains of um
human life that you know there's
variation in effect size but but yeah
it's some of these effects are
tremendous and of course we we do you
know through standard statistical
procedure we do controls too of
potential confounders in all these
analyzes so that's that's at the you
know you do the regional stuff with
countries of the world
um states of the United States in
relation to values and parasite level
but then this stuff coming along with
looking at individuals uh really is is
is nice too because you've got the you
got the same patterns and the reasons
yeah and the individual level right so
we should take that apart a little bit
so the problem with comparing Nations is
there's lots of differences between
nations that might be correlated with
parasites but then if you go to the
state by state level within a country
you you you control for lots of those
variations you have you have and also in
your analysis itself you do uh you do
statistical controls of things that
potentially could be problematic
confounds whether you're looking at
between countries or between states
so we we we have data from all all those
levels the some of the more recent stuff
it's coming out now people are doing uh
they did a lot with the slideshow that I
mentioned there were 10 slides that were
reliably will evoke greater conservatism
but then now they're looking at um
um showing people uh
uh like a short story about covid uh
Cove it's real serious in your
neighborhood or something like that you
know and that does it too so do you
think there'll be a swing towards
conservative political belief in across
the world because of the because of this
pandemic will that shape the political
beliefs of of a an Israel is there a
crucial period for that to be shaped so
for example will this have a bigger
effect on say 14 to 16 year olds or 16
to 18 year olds who are catalyzing their
identity would you would would there be
a cohort that would be most effective
that's a really interesting point and
I've thought a lot about it we don't
there's no there's no there's no data on
that now so if you I mean the way that
you could empirically uh attack such a
thing would be to look at
um to look at people of different ages
in relation to like the effect of these
experiments on them do you get a bigger
effect size when you when you show
slides the disease slides to one age
group versus another yeah or would it
last longer
we don't know how long it'll last either
that research surprisingly has not been
done you bring people into the lab
and um you're showing these slots and
you get the effect also one one Nuance
of that is if you measure
the what we call the perceived
vulnerability to disease that's a that's
a 14 item questionnaire it's validated
and measures a person's uh concern about
infectious disease and that's an
individually variable thing
more conservative people are the higher
their score on that of course and worry
about infectious disease so people that
are high on this uh going into the
experiment show a bigger effect
when they see the slides
they shift more in terms of degree of
conservatism do you know if there's any
effects of Personality on that so if
that hadn't been looked at hasn't been
done yet but it would there would be
some covariance there because the people
that are high and worry about infectious
disease are basically conservative
people so they're going to have less
openness to you know uh new things and
more introversion and all that kind of
stuff oh really yeah so when I first
came across your parasite stress
hypothesis I was reading a fair bit of
the literature on disgust generated a
fair bit of it by Jonathan height and
his research team because he was one of
the first psychologists to look at
discussed as an independent emotion and
but I was reading a book called Hitler's
table talk which was a collection of his
spontaneous utterances at meal times
collected over about three years and it
it really affected my reading of it
because the number of times that he
referred that he used parasite metaphors
really stuck in my mind and I started to
look at all of the Nazi propaganda from
before the second world war in terms of
parasite stress hypothesis especially
after I also realized that Hitler
Hitler's extermination campaign arguably
had its origins in public health policy
because they started out with
tuberculosis interventions and then they
went to clean up the Mental Hospitals
and so on and like the the you know and
Hitler went on a factory cleanup binge
essentially after coming to power and
they used a variant of cyclone gas as an
insecticide in the factory cleanups so
this was all quite terrifying reading
what you were writing and reading this
at the same time and I don't know what
you I mean I'm going to ask you to
comment about that what you think about
that but yeah the metaphor for parasites
that's that's a fundamental meta the
Germans the Nazis seem to view
themselves as under assault by parasites
most selenium is the same way
so you said Mussolini was the same way
exactly the same way he was a he was
just a replica
or Hitler a replica of him
um Mussolini was you know his fascist uh
dictator of uh Italy when Lily was
passionate and uh Hitler fascist uh
leader of uh Nazi uh she doesn't but uh
Mussolini
he he for example outlawed uh
handshaking in Italy he thought it was
the most disgusting thing to touch a
person's hand he was as much germaphobe
as as Hitler and Hitler based four times
a day
that's still going out in some parts of
the world these 30-minute showers in the
Middle East people talk about where you
get the highly conservative people that
really clean up
um but with regard to Fascism I've been
very interested in fascism of course
because it's over there on the on the
extreme pole of conservative end of
things you know it's got all the
components of conservatism in writ large
and uh so I've been interested in new
origin of fascism in in uh in Germany
and uh in Italy and Japan about the same
time the three the three big fascisms
have been some other fascisms too
but a recent study you'll be interested
to know has looked at infectious disease
in German regions cities
in relation to uh voting
for Nazi for for Hitler's party
nationalist Socialist Party
and the more uh the more the way it
works
is so he he had he has data from uh 1918
to 1920
the number of Spanish flu cases
I never thought about Spanish flu as a
contributor because that came right
after World War One of course and yeah
right after World War it was one of the
things that devastated an already
devastated Germany yeah yeah
in the world in general yep yep uh
Germany was really hit hard by uh
by the Spanish Flu as Italy was
uh two and um
and what this guy did he got data
there's a there's a data collection
managed by the University of Michigan
on the third the data from Third Reich
and before the Third Reich became
officially a Third Reich in Germany
and these data include the number of
cases of death due to
Spanish Flu in all these German cities
also they got number of deaths from
um from plague and tuberculosis and so
forth uh too tuberculosis was was still
a big problem by that point too it
wasn't just it wasn't just Spanish flu
but it fast food was the main killer but
tuberculosis probably number two
like one a bigger deal by that point
so these data these data uh have number
of votes
uh in these different cities
for the uh Nazi party
to have the number of votes for the
Communist party and number of votes for
various things so the the the Communist
party was considered extremist then as
was the Nazi party
um and uh the votes are from uh let's
see the years 1930 to 1933 I think so
the critical years uh for the rise of uh
for really Nazism to
get being there and uh the more the more
people dying from the Spanish Flu in
1918 to 1920
Inner City
the greater the vote for the Nazi party
in 1930-33
so uh so that's a connection that's that
was of interest to me and this paper is
just uh it's recently appeared any idea
about the size of the relationship and
and what about economic
are there are there confounds of
economic well-being in the city very
important he controlled he was able to
control through the same data set
for uh employment in those cities and
for average wages in those cities two
variables related to related to economic
State I mean that that's the traditional
thing historians will tell you well the
Germans were so uh economically
distraught that they bought this stuff
you know but uh the parasite stress
Theory values adds a new uh new new
mirror here I think for uh for fascism
in Italy I've searched and searched for
data on
um on uh flu death uh in Italy
but I don't think there's going to be
anything like it for some reason a Third
Reich is you know collected lots and
lots of data and um
somehow University of Michigan I don't
know the history of of the acquisition
by the University of Michigan of these
data but it is a uh it is a reliable
data source that is used now in
sociological and research
now you studied other elements of
parasite stress Theory too its
relationship with altruism it's
relationship with human cognitive
abilities yeah yeah so um yeah what we
did uh we did study of uh IQ in relation
to parasite stress and um across the
world and across the states in the U.S
and that uh worked out very well they
the thinking was was simply that
if you've got uh
you know you think about that human
immune system it is tremendous it's
everywhere in the body and it's very
very costly uh system in terms of the
energy and in terms of tissue to uh to
make and maintain this immune system
humans have this huge brain too very
sophisticated nervous system that is
very costly so we assumed that these two
components of the body immune system and
and nervous system would trade off
and so under under high infectious
disease you got to make a good immune
system or you're going to die
but that's going to cost you in terms of
uh neural development and so forth so we
predicted that more infectious disease
lower IQ predicted it for across regions
of the of the world uh countries and and
states and so we went to the IQ
literature which is massive that's a big
Topic in psychology as you know study of
IQ and there were data for essentially
all the countries of the world
and there were data for the states uh
and we pulled those and looked at the
predictions and uh the predictions were
met for both across across national uh
predictions about point a between
parasite stress and uh IQ more parasites
lower IQ 0.8 for the U.S it's about 0.7
U.S states within States yeah
between the 50 states you take you take
average IQ okay so so let's let's pull
back just a bit for everybody I mean
it's important for everyone who's
listening to realize just how important
a role infectious disease actually plays
in the shaping of human evolution
cultural Evolution included so for
example there are estimates correct me
if I'm wrong Dr Thornhill but there are
estimates that 90 to 95 percent of the
Native inhabitants of North and South
America died as a consequence of contact
with Europeans because of the
transmission of measles smallpox and
mumps primarily although they were also
prone to many other diseases that were
brought in by the Europeans who had
lived in tight-packed cities often with
animals as close companions had had uh
what would you say exposure to a wide
variety of extremely toxic diseases
developed immunity but then brought
those diseases to the new world and
basically decimated the entire
population right so this is a non
trivial event by any City the Europeans
by the time they started moving out of
Europe into the new world uh the
Europeans uh I mean they had all their
diseases but they had relative immunity
to lots of respiratory diseases turns
out
and uh so they brought all that stuff
over here and killed most of the Native
new world people yeah agree mostly so I
had read that when the when the pilgrims
hit Plymouth the natives were desperate
to see them because they had lost so
many people they couldn't Harvest their
crops yeah
yeah it was uh it was a mess and
continued to be a mess a long time yeah
right so so when when isolated
populations of human beings have come
into contact in the past the upside is
the trading of cultural resources
essentially and that can be a tremendous
upside but the downside is the exception
of infectious diseases that's right and
we're caught between those two
catastrophe well those two an
opportunity and a catastrophe which
present themselves simultaneously
yes openness and a little just
liberalism uh is is great uh in terms of
its benefits you got interaction with
lots of different kind of people you get
a bigger social network got a bigger
mating pool uh you know you don't care
if if they're different from you you
want to interact with them and you can
innovate out of catastrophe yeah new
ideas new ideas Innovations you coming
from the outside that you can use
locally uh but that'll only work under
low infectious disease because we get
high infectious disease all that uh out
Group contact uh interaction okay yeah
yeah well that's that's exactly what
we've seen in the last two year and a
half too yes absolutely
so we're right in the middle of it we're
right in the middle of it and the
mortality and you know the the more
human mortality from infectious disease
before the pandemic
uh was still greater than any other
measured source so there's a recent work
that's looked at well you you can just
sort of summarize it this way you can
look at
you can look at
uh genes
that are that have uh that play known
roles in human life
so they're genes associated with
immunity
and those have been described by
immunologists which which genes are
involved
their genes involved in diet the genes
involved in digesting
protein and all that kind of stuff all
these you know Gene uh functions are
known
if you then you you look at where in the
human genome there's the most turnover
of new alleles new genes
those are genes that are evolutionarily
very active
it turns out that the immunity genes are
the evolutionary hot spots in the human
genome and that says there's more
mortality from infectious disease than
from other measured uh problems that
humans face most mortality still is from
infectious disease that was done at 50
sites human science so that that
provides evidence that that's actually
the worst threat facing the worst threat
absolutely still yeah hence its powerful
effect on such things as values yeah
absolutely absolutely it's the main
mortality factor and if you look at the
anthropological evidence about the
importance of infectious disease versus
other things
um there's a lot of evidence for that a
nice review recently that some people
did
um but infectious disease is the main
killer of infants and older children
um in the ethnographic records of you
know traditional societies uh infectious
disease is the big one next is
infanticide that's number two where
parents killer kids uh strategically
because they can't raise them under
resource limitation or or the kids are
sick or whatever in fantasize very
common that's number two but infectious
disease is the main killer
so okay so here's some radical ideas I
suppose because I mean reading all this
learning this
okay let before we go there let's do one
other thing main objections to the
theory practical and and and empirical
what's what I read a paper recently and
I'm I'm afraid I can't cite it in detail
but it'll serve as an example claiming
that with proper control for
technological development the causal or
the effect of parasite stress on
political belief vanished now you cite
many many papers in your books and in
your paper so I'm by no means saying
that this is a canonical study but it's
very use this is a very very very very
very provocative Theory I mean it
opt-ins in some sense my sense when I
first encountered it was that it up and
almost everything we think about
politically and so it and and what
what's the saying that that
extraordinarily claims require
extraordinary evidence we've got to look
at the counter evidence too so what do
you think are the main weaknesses of the
idea as far as you're concerned and how
have you addressed them and have they
been successfully addressed yeah uh
which we had we had we've addressed them
as they have come out and the parasite
stress theory of values has gotten uh
when it first came out I got so much
attention that that attracted a lot of
people to try to falsify you know and
that's the way that works in science
yeah thank God we went through that we
went through that phase and now uh all
the research is uh looking at very
interesting spin-offs in productive ways
of the parasite stress Theory and um no
criticisms have come out recently but
the kind of thing you're talking about
where you know it's really modernity my
modern things and so forth right that
controls our bed that's a that's an old
idea in uh in the literature that um you
know basically people just get more
modern they get more liberal and uh so
forth and and we take that on in a
number of ways and the one way I'd like
to uh you might be interested in we look
at the uh the cultural uh and social
revolution of the 60s and 70s in the
West
so what happened
and I was there
uh you had uh you had a liberalization
of Vegas basically is the bottom line
but you have more uh uh you know uh more
uh you know the women's movement started
then uh there was a sexual Revolution
same time right which aides put the put
a terrible crimp in another infectious
agent
yeah and uh and uh
uh ethnic groups that minority groups
that have been ostracized and so forth
got more attention positive attention it
was democratization of law or voter
voter laws and all that changed so you
can and it was it was more than just
people talk about that time as the
sexual Revolution time 60s and 70s but
really it was a it was a much broader
social Revolution involving human rights
uh increasing human rights and Liberties
basically liberalization so what the
hell happened well here's what happened
it was infectious disease changes that
began in the 20s
that led to all these liberals in the
west uh in the 1670s and these
infectious disease changes
with the control of infectious diseases
like malaria Yeah well yeah bigger than
that it started out in 1920 with uh
fluorinated water that started in the
west we're talking to the West the East
and the rest of the world didn't change
they didn't go through the social
Revolution many places in the world
still haven't because of disease levels
are high and all of Africa basically
much of Asia
um but 1920s chlorinated water started
in the west and quickly spread
throughout uh the Western World by the
Western world I mean U.S Canada uh
Western Europe Australia New Zealand
those places
um so
so chlorinated water and that knocked
out lots and lots of infectious disease
put a little fluorine in public water
also in the 20s began some systematic
garbage collection before people just
threw the garbage out there howling
sewage treatment plants started then too
too and there was more indoor plumbing
in the starting in the 20s
now let's jump to the 40s 40s big big
changes with regard to emancipation from
parasites
had a child vaccination programs that
began in the 40s
also antibiotics
first good antibiotics right after World
War II 1945.
in the 40s so this was really by that
point a new world
in terms of lowered infectious disease
compared to the world that all
generations of humans had experienced in
the west prior to those 20s and 40s
there were some antibiotics in the 30s
but sulfur drugs and so forth but they
had terrible side effects so the real
good antibiotics didn't come along until
the 40s and broad spectrum kind of
antibiotics
and of course that spread is so rapidly
that the use of antibiotics that they
quickly saw a resistance to antibiotics
popping up you know the evolution of
resistance and parasites
uh yes which is a serious problem we
have now because we have diseases that
are resistant to almost all the broad
spectrum absolutely even in common
that's a looming catastrophe which we
should obviously pay attention to right
arms race between the parasites and the
drug companies now with that
uh so up to the 40s and then also in the
40s
uh you had
um insecticides coming along good
insecticides chlorinated hydrocarbons
and organophosphate sector size that
killed uh pest species including
mosquitoes
so uh vectors important vectors of
disease in the in the in the uh in the
west mosquitoes uh so that knocked out
malaria knocked out yellow fever with
that
and
um and uh so all that was going on to
emancipate people and then the
generation two or two later
you get the rise of liberalism
throughout the West so all these liberal
young people growing up in a relatively
disease-free environment by all these by
all these Health interventions
uh became the hippies and so they were
healthy enough to be free yeah
and so that does really raise the
question again of what covid is this
covid pandemic and the lockdown is going
to do to the political temperament of
the west or the world for that matter
but right it's a particular change in
the west because we're not accustomed to
this sort of thing anymore right so it's
so interesting because of course I've
thought of the the liberalism Revolution
being a secondary derivative of the
birth control pill which is a biological
revolution of immense magnitude but I
hadn't ever considered in depth even
afterwards I mean the use of birth
control and all that by women that's
that that takes some willingness to try
a new things right exactly well that's
it that might be dependent itself on one
away from tradition uh you know taking
birth control so there's another
perverse implication of the theory that
you've developed too which is that
conservatism insistence upon hygiene and
disease prevention is a precondition for
liberalism
if it's successful right so it's in some
sense the conservatives are battling off
the disease
so that people can stay healthy but the
consequence of that is as soon as that
they're healthy they become liberal
yeah yeah isn't that something yeah well
I think it's here's you can look at it
like this
so if you've got high conservatism in a
place
then those conservatives
are doing things
that promote
uh well they're you know
they're not they're not uh they're not
using modern technology they're not you
know open to new ideas they're not open
to science and all that so those are
those are attitudes that help the
Infectious Disease really right right
right right right so the Reliance on
traditional that's right traditionalism
is also an imperative tremendous
impediment it reduces their contact
immediately
so it works against them that way I mean
if you're not you know Pro science and
uh open to new ideas and Innovations and
all that kind of stuff that is
tremendous limitations and uh so you
know you don't even put in septic tanks
and you think
or chlorinate the water or okay so so
another patient you don't get a
vaccination right well okay so let's
talk about two things then one is I've
been struck didn't tell me what you
think about this
the covid has become a politicized issue
in Canada and in the U.S but it doesn't
seem to have happened the way you might
have predicted if you were relying on
parasite stress Theory because it seems
to be that the conservative types are
the ones who are objecting most
strenuously to the lockdowns and to the
inoculations whereas the liberal types I
mean and maybe I'm wrong about this but
seem to be more uh in favor of the of
restrictions of movement and so on and
that that actually I don't I can't get
my head around that exactly yeah no
you're right that is the pattern and
that's been studied now and uh you know
there's some papers on it
um and here's the way here's what's
going on I think
in the U.S in particular uh
the
the conservative government at the time
when covet was getting off the ground
the Trump Administration
uh was very negative about code I mean
he called it hoax and all that didn't
believe it and uh it's no problem and
um so
that is the authority we need to talk
about authoritarianism because here's
this is where it comes in
you have the king Donald Trump
saying that it's no problem this disease
is no problem and it's just going to go
away it's a hoax and all that kind of
stuff
and that that is
the word from God basically two highly
liberal uh conservative people and
that's the way authoritarianism worked
people that are highly authoritarian and
that's conservatives that's strong
there's a lot of evidence there
authoritarianism is is very highly uh
correlated with uh conservatism in fact
a component of it
the more the more authoritarian the
people are the more likely they will
follow these guys that they that they
label as their leader and to the point
that they'll follow them anywhere they
fall them off a cliff basically as they
did in in Germany
as they did in Italy and as they did in
the United States during this covet tank
so you believe that what happened was
that the evidence that there was in fact
a dangerous epidemic was rendered
non-credible and so that's right
conservative tendency to prevent the
disease didn't kick in that's right
exactly and do you think that's a good
prevented it was the authoritarianism
that conservatives are carrying and had
Trump acted another way you know said
this disease is really important I want
you folks to wear a mask and uh be
careful and distance and all that kind
of stuff then there would have been a
different outcome because that would
have been the authority message
so it's one it's one element of of
authoritarianism slash conservatism
interfering with another that's right uh
okay
um
parasite stress and sex
yeah
there's been some uh some look at uh
values in relation to sex so
conservatism conservatives are
conservative
so but there's there's old studies that
um
there's a there's one paper I should
send you it's you got all kinds of
correlations in there with everything
under the sun in relation to
conservatism and liberalism but uh you
know interest in uh uh interest in
um
uh different you know different
positions copulatory positions and all
that you did the conservatives more
likely to stick to the missionary style
and whereas the Liberals are uh more uh
adventurous with regard guard to
position and is and is there a
relationship that between
adventurousness and sexual position and
the risk of transmitting sexually
transmitted diseases don't know I
haven't seen anything on that particular
uh thing but you know Liberals are more
more interested in uh
would be more interested in partners
that are in different ethnic groups I
mean that's been studied you don't limit
your your sexual interests just to your
end group if you're liberal you're happy
with people of different color and
different uh backgrounds and all that
kind of stuff as as sex partners so so
those kinds of things have been done
uh with regard to sexual behavior we did
a we did
we did the variable
um
social sexual orientation it's a it's a
variable it's validated
um
in Psychology and it's it measures
really a person's attitude about uh
promiscuity or or sex without commitment
you call it sex without commitment and
that varies among individuals their
attitude about sex uh without commitment
and we looked and they're data on uh I
think it was uh 120 countries uh
measures so we took those data and
looked at them in relation to parasite
stress and values and um the more the
more parasites
the uh the
less uh uh less interest that women show
in non-committal sex so the more
parasites
and that's Pro that's mediated I presume
by a cultural response to the presence
of the parasites yeah right that's
conservatism yeah and I will have any
studies been done
that are analogous to the
the political studies where where people
are shown images that are reminiscent of
of parasitic presence and then asked
about their sexual preferences with
regards to monogamy or uncommitted
relationships no that hadn't been done
no that hadn't been done
no there's a PhD thesis for someone and
yeah we just did the we just took the
SOI data social uh sexual orientation
inventory data for men and women across
these countries and looked at it in
relation to parasite stress and and
values and uh as I mentioned it as as uh
infectious disease increases women show
more restriction as and as women
specifically women specifically the
effect for men is not reliable this is
not very big and probably not even
reliable statistically significant but
for women it's highly significant we're
more parasites the more restricted women
are and that goes along with
conservatism so conservatism there's a
sexual Purity and protect the jewels
kind of attitude that is instilled by a
conservative culture in women so but in
women in well so there's a question okay
you know it's a double standard well
when you get parasite stress increasing
then
is the conservative proclivity
manifested to begin with in the women
and then spread to the men
I mean because they're more primarily
concerned let's say with sexual
contamination I mean the role of the
genders and determining but the manner
the men are changing the men are
changing and other components uh so
they're the men are hot to trot
regardless of well that's what I was
thinking yeah but but the men are the
men are changing in terms of uh becoming
Moors andophilic and uh ethnocentric and
those kinds of things you know yeah so
the sexual changes don't drive the rest
of it no okay because I mean changes in
sexual behavior often Drive changes in
other phenomena can be important yeah
yeah you also write about parasite
stress and religiosity yeah we did uh
a big study of that looking at religion
Scholars
uh looking at their data
on uh commitment and participation
of people in religion across um
basically all the countries of the world
and we had State data too we had U.S
state data on participation and uh
commitment of people and predicting that
more parasites more religiosity
measured either as commitment or
participation
and uh more conservatism of course more
religiosity that's well known already
more conservative uh people uh those
would be traditional markers of
religiosity like church intent such as
Church attendance yeah rather than
spirituality sometimes a month you go to
church uh and a stated commitment that
you have do you believe uh do you
believe in the local religion that kind
of thing
uh this religious Scholars you know have
done that done a good job and then
published all that in the literature so
you pull their data and then look at in
relation to uh parasite stress more
parasites more religious people are and
we expected it from following uh uh
ideas that
was known that religiosity is very
tightly correlated with conservatism
before that had been shown by lots of
folks in the past
but religiosity has uh has uh some
couple of parts to it that were of
interest to us from the standpoint of
the parasite stress Theory one is the uh
boundary issue that religions often show
so in fact religion Scholars uh Define
religions in terms of boundary so this
group over here believes in this God
group over here believes in this God are
gods and so forth so those are boundary
markers
yes and so the boundary would would be
like a xenophobic kind of function you
know to to about to bound to end group
out group kind of Separation the other
part of religiosity that was of interest
uh from the standpoint of the parasite
stress theory is the ethnocentric part
so you get that in group binding with
your with your colleagues at church and
so forth that can be extremely strong
and
um so that there we looked at it in
found that uh basically a new theory of
religion that more parasites more
religiosity across countries the world
and and States of uh and what sort of
effect size is that
uh those uh I don't remember offhand uh
big effects uh I mean it was we
published in a major brain and
Behavioral Sciences a major you know top
top tier Journal uh but again you could
you know back to your earlier question
about showing people these immediate
parasite threats the slides are some
other way that they're manipulating that
now they're doing all kinds of things
with that
um and see if people get believed in God
more or something like that immediately
that would be cool yes yes it would be
and you changed interesting belief in
Spirits by uh by that uh well you also
wonder too if you know
I'm just thinking here ideas are just
flashing through my mind about beliefs
and spirit to begin with because the
belief in spirit causing illness for
example is sort of a an early analog of
a disease Theory you know yeah yeah I
mean people are wrong yeah there's a
study uh I can't remember exactly what
it is got her in my pile over here
uh the claims
that the fundamental belief we have in a
spiritual world
really boils down to
spirits
as diseases it's disease-causing
entities but they are invisible agents
that are just invisible after all but
you you can transmit them too yes with
the evil eye and all this other uh stuff
in cultures that um
suggest transmission of uh of this of
this spirit and of course before the
germ Theory uh before germs were known
parasites were known to cause disease
it was all invisible
so
Spirits feel that
and um
which is you know as as witches as uh
channels
for the evil that these Spirits have
that's part of it too and the
Inquisition and so forth and so on all
that's real cool and everything that's
unknown right because well that and it's
down to a disease right right right and
they were right the disease was killing
everybody most of the people anyway you
know so um yeah
well you know that was all actually too
interesting I guess I'd like to close
with this so you've been studying this a
long time and it's very
unexpected it's a very unexpected Theory
I would say what how has knowing this
how is studying this changed the way you
look at society and people and political
dialogue I mean you're in this position
I've only been digesting the material
you've been producing for about five
years I would say maybe maybe ten yeah
it hasn't permeated my thought system
entirely but you've been wrestling this
with this for three decades two decades
anyways
actually in a sense all my life let me
explain I I was born and raised and uh
in the Old South Heart of Dixie Alabama
so I was born into a culture that hadn't
really changed in a hundred years
except they had cars and stuff but
ideologically there had been no change
since the Civil War
very conservative place
and um
for reasons I I may you know I think
about a lot how come I came out of it
liberal rather than a conservative
um
uh I you know would say you know I would
find what these people were doing day in
day out I seen your face all the time if
you live in a conservative culture
uh of the inhumanity
and uh
and you know why are they doing that and
what's wrong with you people that kind
of thing and then finally Hill I just
decided uh I was gonna step back and uh
just try to think about it study it and
I finally got around to that uh in my
scientific research most of my research
was on sexual selection processes and so
forth I only got into the value stuff
about uh year 2000.
and um
and uh so I've had this in
in the very very strong interests
in how these people I grew up with got
to be that way
then when I went off to University
I went into a relatively liberal place
so I was then I became interested in how
these people how these liberals got
there got their mindset too I was more
like them
and um
so I'm I go back a long way in my
interest in this and the you know it
it's just it's been really satisfying
to to understand the cause you know to
do the science on it and really
understand the causal stuff and stuff
that happened uh in my family and so
forth I mean you know I'm I'm trying to
do a popular book for the intelligent
reader on all this
but uh it was one incident where in in
in the Old South uh middle class and
upper class families white families
would hire a a black woman to raise the
kids or black women to raise kids and my
family did that
and I was closer to this woman really in
many ways than I was my birth mother
and she died when I was 13.
my black mama died
and um she got sick
and my family wouldn't let me go see her
when she was sick
because uh she was sick and they were
conservative and they were worried about
me I mean they were trying to protect me
but I didn't understand that at the time
and in my mind she was my mother she she
raised me
she was with me every day
and uh
sometime I was born until she died when
she was 13. but I couldn't go see her
and finally let me
go to her house she did a little Shack
wouldn't Shack on the other side of the
tracks so to speak
and uh because it was Regional
segregation everything was surrogated
and uh so let me stand on the porch and
talk to her she was inside in the bed
dying
when I could talk to her own
the porch
and we talked and she died uh five days
after that
and they didn't even my family wouldn't
even allow them didn't even tell me
whether she was buried and so forth I
mean there was that level of
uh conservatism and worry about disease
and I'd go to her grave or something and
catch a disease but what this knowledge
of values has helped me with is things
like that events and there are lots of
them in my upbringing
that were devastating uh because of the
con you know conservative values that I
was dealing with terrible things
happening and um
so I think that's one thing that really
has sparked my my interest
in values
and then of course I'm liberal now how
do I get that way I mean my high school
it was a High School uh
Decatur Alabama is where I grew up in
high school of graduating class of about
200. and there were about three liberals
in the class
and I was one and I'm one of my close
friends he was a liberal he's he's uh
he's a civil rights lawyer in South
Alabama now
and another one friend close friend of
mine she's level she works for the
Democratic party and Washington DC
but other the most of the rest of them
were pretty conservative and um
I wonder how I got out of this and my
hypothesis is
um that
I had
an interesting genetic Constitution
because
my uh part of my family was Native
American
and so Native American uh in north
Alabama Cherokee
and so those folks had the local amenity
uh to the infectious diseases that were
endemic to that region the Native
Americans so I got that genetic
complement
and also got the European genetic
complement which had pretty good
immunity to lots of respiratory diseases
and that's another story
we could work on
um but um so I got this this odd genetic
compliment Native American plus northern
European the thornhills the northern
European
and that that reduced my interaction
with infectious disease growing up
so like unlike the kids around me I
didn't have all those ear infections I
didn't have all those eye infections
growing up and
um unlike most of my friends
and so I think that's it because I think
that's part of the ontogeny the
developmental background of the values
that is you're going through you're
going you're growing up
and how often is your immune system
activated and how long is your immune
system activated when it's activated
that's part of the uh developmental
background uh that we propose for for
values if your immune system is
activated a lot and you end up
conservative because not you end up
liberal so I think all that is is uh
part of my interest in this too yeah if
I've been born somewhere else maybe I'd
have never gotten interested in values
than in the Old South you know
well I think that's a really good place
to end I don't want to end because
there's like 50 other things I'd like to
ask you but that's been great talking
with you well thank you and it's so
interesting your research is is like I
said it's too interesting actually you
suggested some good experiments so I'm
gonna think about it yeah yeah well
they're they're they're causal
experiments and they're all actually
relatively straightforward I'm supposed
to be retired now uh and uh but I'm
trying to do this this uh
Popular Science book and it'd also be
interesting to see if there's any
relationship between
even self-reported prevalence of
amount of time ill during childhood and
Adolescence and trade openness
there there is a there is a scientific
study of of illness two studies of
illness during childhood reported
illness during childhood is one of the
studies
and can serve some some components of
conservatism I don't remember if the
openness is there but some and that
works and then there's another one where
they had uh they looked at
actually health records
of children
who then became adults and have adults
and then you have their health records
and they did that and showed that the uh
less Health the kid had as a as a child
the more conservative they were
um
so that kind of that kind of stuff is
out there so then okay so maybe we could
we could let me ask you what you think
about this when I first came across your
work I thought
is it possible that
the human race could rescue itself from
the worst excesses of the kind of
conservatism that degenerates into
malevolent fascism essentially by wiping
out infectious disease I think the
answer to that is straightforward yes
Jesus yeah absolutely uh the uh
you know I want to emphasize that it's a
parasite stress theory of values
parasite stress theory of values and
sociality is assigned to Theory and
hence
it doesn't have any doesn't make any
moral judgments about you know it
doesn't say conservatism is more moral
than liberalism or vice versa scientific
theory no no value judgments involved
there because it's scientific theory but
if one wanted to
change the values of the future
of people
uh they then you have to know of course
what the causes of the of values are
that's the way you change things you
know you know causes of things and you
can change them then uh you if you want
to make the world more liberal uh you
would reduce infectious disease
you wanted to make the world a place
where the cost for the free exchange of
ideas and people was dramatically
reduced so that the countervailing
tendency to that was unnecessary yeah
and and the catastrophes that might go
along with an excess of that
countervailing proclivity the most
effective way forward would be to
eradicate infectious disease and so and
then you'd have the benefit of
eradicating the disease which would be
non-trivial plus you'd have the
political benefit it will be healthier
lower morbidity and healthier throughout
their lives and uh also they'd be open
and uh you know sort of the reaching the
goal of the true enlightenment
which was all about you know freedom of
thought and individuality
um science
um knowledge all that stuff right all
entirely laudable goals except when the
cost becomes too high yeah when diseases
are out there well so I've been talking
to people like Bjorn lomberg and Matt
Ridley and the and and yeah and I know
you know they're they're people who have
a a positive Enlightenment view of the
future and are having a hard time in
some sense along with the rest of us
generating something like
what would you say a noble vision for
the future that moderates could get
behind and be motivated by and it
certainly seems in light of this
discussion that and of what's happened
with covid-19
Etc and the fact that infectious
diseases are still a primary killer and
not only that crippler of people all
around the world and that they
contribute radically to all sorts of
political instability that one thing we
could all agree on would be that less
infectious diseases would be better yeah
absolutely absolutely and um you know I
have a pretty positive view of the
future like you've you've uh I noticed
in your uh website that you interviewed
Steve Pinker yep ready he's in the same
group in some senses these other people
that I just mentioned you know they're
they're optimistic Enlightenment figures
yeah I can be optimistic and and I mean
he sees he has data on how much things
have improved over the last several
centuries and that's because of lower
infectious disease I mean he doesn't
have a theory his was his his ideas just
stops it hell thinks people got
enlightened but how come they got into
like you know why the enlightenment
occur and why did we allow it to occur
yeah exactly
absolutely get better and better wanted
wanted
mortality and you know uh homicides and
wars and all that reduce and frequency
and uh all the evidence we put together
says it has to do with lower infectious
disease through time that's what
happened that's what's behind that Trend
that's why that's that's that's the key
to our better angels
thank you very much
sure I appreciate it was great
discussion I really I learned a lot and
uh your work it's remarkable anytime
yeah well uh
I may call on May well call on you again
[Music]